good evening we start with breaking news
and the turmoil within the SNP the
party's Treasurer Colin Beatty is
stepping back from the role and also
from Hollywood's public audit committee
police are continuing to investigate the
snp's finances and funding particularly
a 600 000 pound pot earmarked for an
independence campaign let's bring in uh
Scotland a correspondent Connor Gillis
and Connor in the circumstances perhaps
no great surprise
no great surprise given this live police
investigation given the fact that Colin
Beatty was detained by those detectives
spent hours facing questions from those
very police officers yesterday around
the funding the financing of the SNP
this is a man who has been at the helm
as treasurer for a considerable period
of time not a high-profile political
figure with the public but certainly a
senior high-ranking official within the
SNP party Colin Beatty was the treasurer
of the SNP for a period of 16 years up
until 2020 then for a moment or two uh
was not re-elected and then subsequently
returned to that role which he has been
in until the last couple of minutes let
me just read you the statement from
Colin Beatty uh we have here let's have
a look this afternoon I informed the
party leader that I will be stepping
thing bought from my role as SNP
National Treasurer with immediate effect
I have also informed the SNP Chief whip
at holyroots that I will be stepping
back from my role on the public audit
committee until the police investigation
has concluded he continues on a personal
level this decision has not been easy
but it is the right decision to avoid
further distraction to the important
work being led by Hamza Yusuf to improve
the snp's governance and transparency
and Colin Beatty concludes I will
continue to cooperate fully with police
Scotland inquiries and it would be
inappropriate for me to comment any
further on a live case now this leaves
the new first minister of Scotland the
new SMP leader Hamza Yusuf in an
incredibly tricky position because the
party is now without a permanent chief
executive following the resignation of
uh Peter model the former first minister
of the Nicholas dargin's husband and now
it leaves no one in charge of the smp's
finances at a time that those very
finances are under extreme scrutiny from
police Scotland this is our time as well
when the SNP was hoping to reset the
conversation around uh the policy
platform going forward again that has
caused further issues with the uh change
in direction from the police
investigation over the course of the
last couple of days earlier today as
well I interviewed the deputy uh first
minister of Scotland Shona Roberson she
was at a government event again trying
to change the conversation and the uh
conversation clearly turned back to the
state of the SNP and the Scandal
engulfing it at the moment a party that
is paralyzed let's get a flavor of
exactly what Shona Roberson taught me
just a few hours ago
the party has to get its house in order
that's what the public would expect the
public would also expect as though as a
government to tackle the issues of
importance to them not least the cost of
living crisis and of course that's what
the policy perspectives yesterday was
focused upon your admission there that
the party needs to get its house in
order seems to suggest that under
Nicholas sturgeon your friend and close
colleague things were not quite right so
did she have too tight a ship in the way
that the SMP was run in recent years
that has culminated in this mess that
we're all viewing now well look I don't
think anyone is going to dispute that
the governance Arrangements in the party
were not as they should be and we are
talking about the the result of some of
that now and so those governance
Arrangements absolutely need to be
overhauled Nicola sturgeon's fault
though isn't it well I'm not sure it
just is with Nicholas sturgeon here I
think you know everybody perhaps is a
rule to play here and with respect she
was the party leader not resolving some
of these governance issues um but it
probably goes beyond Nicola sturgeon in
terms of perhaps a culture that has been
allowed to develop at headquarters and
in terms of the governance of the party
what kind of culture well I think one
that perhaps needed to be more open and
more transparent and you know people
being able to ask questions
so Connor I mean to sum up huge problems
now clearly facing the new first
minister
former leadership Contender for the SMP
top job Cape Forbes
um saying that the SNP will be in deep
trouble if decisive action is not taken
we've got that admission from another
senior ranking member of the SNP we just
heard from her Shauna Roberson there
saying that the party needs to get its
own house in order and clearly this is a
party that has had transparency issues
what appears to be over the course of
the last couple of years accusations
that anyone who raised concerns anyone
who questioned the leadership of the
party was very quickly sidelined at that
I think has uh in recent times since
Hamza Yusuf took over he's attempted to
try and reset the balance on that and be
more open and Frank in those exchanges
but the reality is he has got a headache
on his hands as he now has to tackle
filling the post of the most senior role
in the SMP the chief executive and no
someone to the place the treasurer role
at a time when those very finances are
under the investigating investigation of
police